which of the following numbers is a
factor of 154 so a number is going to be
a factor of 154 is if we can divide that
number into 154 and not have a remainder
or another way of thinking about it a
number is a factor of 154 if 154 is a
multiple of that number so let's look at
each of these and see which of these we
can we can rule out or say is a factor
so does 3 divide evenly into 154 or
another way of thinking about it is 154
a multiple of 3
well you later learn that you could
actually test whether something is
divisible by 3 by adding up the digits
and if that's divisible by 3 then it's
going to be divisible by 3 and so you
see here 1 plus 5 is 6 6 plus 4 is 10 10
is not divisible by 3 but if you didn't
want to do that little trick and we have
other videos we go into more detail
about that trick you can actually just
divide 3 into 154 3 doesn't go into 1 it
does go into 15 5 times 5 times 3 is 15
subtract then we we have 0 then you
bring down a 4 3 goes into 4 one time 1
times 3 is 3 subtract and you have a
remainder of 1 so 3 is clearly not a
factor of 154 so we can rule that out
now what about 5 well any multiple of 5
is either going to have a 5 or a 0 in
the ones place you see that if we're 5
times 1 is 5 5 times 2 is 10 5 times 3
is 15 5 times 4 is 20 you either have a
5 or a 0 in the ones place this does not
have a 5 or a 0 in the ones place so
it's not going to be divisible by 5 5 is
not a factor 154 is not a multiple of 5
now 6 is interesting you could do the
same thing you could try to divide 6
into 154 but if something is divisible
by 6 it's definitely going to be
divisible by 3 as well because 6 is
divisible by 3 so we can immediately
rule this one out as well because 154 is
not divisible by 3 it's also not going
to be divisible by 6 and you could try
it out if you like and we can make the
same argument for 9 if something is
divisible by 9 its
going to be divisible by 3 because 9 is
divisible by 3 well it's not divisible
by 3 so we're going to rule out 9 as
well so we've ruled out everything it
looks like 14 as our only option but
let's actually verify it let's actually
divide 14 into 154 14 doesn't go into 1
it goes into 15 exactly one time 1 times
14 is 14 we subtract we get 1 bring down
the 4 14 goes into 14 one time 1 times
14 is 14 and of course we have no
remainder so 14 goes into 150 for
exactly 11 times or 11 times 14 is 154
154 is a multiple of 14 let's do one
more which of the following numbers is a
multiple of 14 so now we have 14 we're
trying to think of its multiples so
there's two ways of doing this you could
go number by number and try to divide 14
into them or we could just try to figure
out what all of the multiples of 14
actually are so let's try to do that
let's try to do that second technique 14
times 1 14 times 1 is 14 you add another
14 14 times 2 is 28 add another 14 let's
see add 10 you get to 38 then you add 4
more you get to 42 then you add another
14 I haven't seen any of these numbers
show up yet add another 14 to this you
get 256 still not quite there at another
14 let's see if you had 4 you get to 60
and then you have to add the 10 so then
you get 270 and it looks like we have
found one of these numbers 70 is a
multiple of 14 14 times 1 2 3 4 5 14
times 5 is 70